je le trouve très bien et très bien
conçu quand on voir dans les étapes
on reste le 1er juin un petit peu sur
sur le plat et puis un peu de temps à
ramener les bosses tu nous entends très
tôt sur sur trinité s'est établi à qui a
changé donc impossible quand on voit
bien le ils ont très très bien manoeuvré
par rapport aux étapes et par rapport au
sirop récupération des points je trouve
que c'est un tour bien conçu et haut
niveau les invités les invités justement
ne le connais pas encore mais il faut
vous dire comme ce qu'on a comme un
contrôle comme n'amorce il faut
atteindre tout premier au monde pour
pouvoir vraiment découvrir les invités
et quant au renvoi de la compagnie à une
équipe
de dn1 attend nos voix pour le site
identique est rappelé au début de
pudique saison si parce que nous avons
quand même des gens qui sont en train de
pointer le bout du nez nous avons quand
même qu'à des mois nous avons trois
quatre jeunes donc
on est confiant quand on engage aussi
ceux qui sont en train de faire autour
de marie galante on peut se dire qu'on a
un super taux et des martiniquais qui
vont animer convenablement le château le
tout beaucoup se joue entre deux
montagnes possible le tout se joue aux
dés l'ouverture
bon c'est jamais bon bain comme un bien
pu prendre le maillot il peut y avoir
une grosse équipe
j'ai ri pendant tout le tour et puis
gagner le tour pour me dire que mambé il
faut quand même
c'est ça c'est la préparation donc on
est mieux préparé on a confiance en son
équipe
on peut attaquer très tôt